hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in metaphysics book 1 Aristotle will
make a fundamental distinction between
two different modalities of having
knowledge or know-how if you like one of
which he calls experience or in Greek
and Pater yeah this is something that's
quite familiar to all of us with many of
the things that we we do on a daily
basis that we have experience of and
then the other would be something more
rigorous something that in a certain way
more worthy of being called knowledge
and he uses two different terms here
they tell he does know our different
from each other art or Tech may and
science or a piston may now he tells you
later on in the metaphysics that he's
covered these in the nick of mccain
ethics and we don't need to go into the
discussion here they're really being
used for the purposes of this discussion
as synonyms for each other what's most
important is how they're distinguished
from experience before we get there he
starts out by talking about animals and
we are animal so that's also where we
should begin we get to know the world in
part through the senses through having
sensation or perception a stasis this is
a term that Aristotle uses quite
frequently we're never totally
disconnected from that at least in most
of our concerns and then he talks about
animals as also living by impressions or
appearances fantasy I these are things
that they they perceive coming in from
the world around them and some animals
may not have very many senses at all
some of them may have the full panoply
that we do but Aristotle thinks that
animals other than us are not quite as
developed in how they use these things
only certain animals have the capacity
for what he terms memory
name--a and this is very important
because memory is what allows us to
identify similar instances as similar
instances and not just go by instinct in
a sort of stimulus-response way but to
learn from our environment and our
engagements with it perhaps even to have
something like passing pseudo or proto
knowledge down at the level of animals
he doesn't say that animals are totally
disconnected from what he's calling
experience here as a matter of fact he
holds out the possibility that some of
them do participate in that but they
don't to the degree that human beings do
and from he says many memories of
something arises this distinctive way of
being able to approach things in the
world and situations and other persons
and ourselves that he calls experienced
and paid Riya this is a sort of know-how
or knack or ability to figure things out
without truly knowing these matter
in a universal census we're going to
talk about without being able to provide
a theoretical account of them so you
know what would be examples of this
think about when you ride a bicycle or a
skateboard or any other wheeled thing
did you study a book that I mean you may
have maybe you watched youtube videos
with a step-by-step tutorial and well
first you have to you know put your feet
in this way and you're doing that for
this reason because these principles are
involved I don't know that's not how I
learned to ride a bike I watched other
people do it and then I got my butt on
the seat and put my my feet on the
pedals and I first had training wheels
so I get used to the balancing right and
then after a while of going around and
round with the bike that took my
training wheels off and I started riding
the bike and I was very proud and now I
knew how to ride a bike and riding a
bike is a great example because we used
it in English as a sort of a proverb you
know you it's just like riding a bike
you've learned how to do it once you may
not have done it for a while you can
start to do it again we'll come back to
examples like that in a moment
but in any case we have all sorts of
things that we learn from experience
then we human beings have the
possibility of something that Aristotle
doesn't think animals participate in at
all and he says he doesn't explain it
here but he says that we human beings
live not only by appearances or memories
or those sorts of things but also by art
and by reasoning logi Smouse in the
greek which is not the same thing as
logos but it means sort of the instances
of using logos this capacity for speech
or a reason that is so distinctively
human we live by that we develop
ourselves by that that leads us to the
possibility of art or science these
systemic accumulative disciplines that a
person can have as a disposition
you know when we say that somebody has
studied something we could mean that
they've acquired some experience just
sort of you know watching things and
experimenting or we could mean that
they've actually learned the principles
of it in some sort of systematic well
laid out way and then you know these are
relative terms we're not saying that
anybody acquires art or science to the
absolute highest degree and knows
everything that there is to know about
everything because these grow by
increments Arts and Sciences we add to
them over time and every once in a while
we discover that things that we thought
were correct are actually incorrect I'll
give you a prime example of that I
learned from my physician that what we
were taught when I was a young boy and
then a young man about exercise and
stretching
according to modern Exercise Science is
incorrect instead of stretching a lot
before exercising you should stretch
after it you do want to limber yourself
up before doing exercise but the
stretching turns out to be
counterproductive who knew right that's
an example of revision within the Arts
and Sciences
Aristotle doesn't talk about that here
but it fits his model quite well so
what's the fundamental set of
differences between experience on the
one hand and art or science on the other
hand
Aristotle frames this in terms of what
it is that we actually do know and what
we can do with that so he tells us that
the person who has experience has
knowledge but not of the overarching
generalities they understand particulars
and they understand them quite well so
they understand the Kathak hostile me
you might say in accordance with or
looking down on each thing Acosta's is
you know each right and so if I know how
to fish because I used to go fishing
my father and I understand how to fish
well for bluegill and smallmouth bass
and perch which I do in fact I learned
that I'm doing it with my father as well
as white bass that doesn't mean that I
actually know about fishing as an art or
science per se it means that I know
about how to fish for these kind of fish
and I may actually be an advantage here
in the Midwest where these are the kinds
of fish that you know we often do go for
I actually don't know how to fish well
for crappie or for northern pike because
we didn't do that but I could consult a
book perhaps or somebody who knows and
learn those sorts of things
I suppose I could watch a youtube video
as well but this is knowledge of
particulars and knowledge of particulars
can be quite effective as well we'll
talk about in a moment what about over
on this side here it's knowledge of the
universals the katha loop in Greek
meaning the knowledge no longer just of
the each instance or the separate
classes of things but of the universal
the general the everything so this is a
different kind of knowledge this really
is more knowledge than this is this is
more know-how or being able to recognize
identify things in particular areas and
circumstances this understands in a
different way an arrant we'll come back
to the effectiveness thing in a moment I
want to follow this out Aristotle says
that this person knows the that they
know the toho t that something is the
case so they know for example that in
this kind of circumstance you you should
feed a person this kind of food if you
want to have this kind of effect but
they can't tell you why they don't
actually know the causes they don't
understand as Aristotle says the
wherefore the D
right they understand the Holte but they
don't understand the through what and
they don't know the cause they don't
know the idea in Greek the reason why
things are the way they are we could
come up with all sorts of examples let's
take the fishing one for it for example
so you know my dad who wasn't prone to
explaining too much I came to fishing he
would always tell me the line of the
fish you can hear you so you know let's
all be really quiet I think in part
because he wanted a some peace and quiet
well today in the boat I would sometimes
ask him as I did you know the curious
kid all sorts of questions about why
we're using this bait or why we're doing
things this way and you know I don't
know if he actually had answers or not
but he didn't give me any answers so the
best that he passed on to me was in paid
Rhea would you want to fish for white
bass in these sort of circumstances
let's use some wax worms or some
hellgrammite hey worms maybe won't do it
forget going for bluegill maybe we do
bobber fishing why I don't know because
I never learned the art or science of
fishing in that case I didn't learn the
cause or the wherefore and we could come
up with all sorts of examples of this
think about cooking for a set of
instances there's many people who are
quite good at cooking they know how to
make meals they know how to make
particular dishes but they couldn't tell
you why the dish actually tastes good or
why there should be this amount of this
kind of spice or why vinegar at this
point whereas if we're talking about you
know a scientific approach to the
culinary arts you might say well you
know we have these different tastes and
adding vinegar to the dish at this point
or lemon juice makes the the other
tastes come out better it adds a certain
sourness which balances the saltiness or
the sweetness or you cook for this long
and the reason why you brown the meat is
to get this chemical reaction take place
right and we also know some very
interesting things for example when I'll
give you one for my childhood my
there would marinate meat and the stuff
that he cooked was quite good but what
the you know Test Kitchen people tell us
is that marinades really don't do much
of anything they don't penetrate steak
very far and you're better off just
doing other things instead who knew
again right they knew because they used
art or science to figure it out and I
would have passed down that information
about marinades to my children and
taught them the same thing that my dad
was doing and it would have been wrong
now we can say however that in many
cases experience could be dead-on that's
part of why we follow it in in a lot of
cases and we don't actually go and
acquire scientific knowledge or or
technical skill about everything instead
we do rely on experience because the
person who is well experienced as
aristotle says is quite often more
effective in practical manners so he
uses the example which is you know
something he knew very intimately of
medicine his father was actually a
physician he tells us that a physician
who doesn't actually have art or science
but is just sort of you don't think
about a field medic for example somebody
who learned how to take care of wounded
people how to deal with certain kinds of
common ailments or diseases they often
can be very very effective because they
understand the particulars far better
than the person who merely understands
the universal so the person who
understands universal may not actually
know if they're rather green or
inexperienced when to make exceptions to
those universal rules or how to even
evaluate how to diagnose a particular
case in front of them like Socrates with
having some foot issues you know what
what should we prescribe as he's on the
March it may be that the experienced
person is
better understanding of that for the
time being than the person who is using
art or science there's nothing to say
that you can't combine the two however
the last thing that we want to focus on
here is that the person who has art or
science Aristotle says actually has
knowledge more than the experienced
person does they also are closer to
wisdom than the experienced person and
one sign of this is that they can teach
other people now
you might say well wait a second didn't
your dad teach you how to fish or how to
marinate meat or any of those sorts of
things didn't you learn how to play
soccer by you know actually getting out
there and playing on the field and the
coach making you do certain things we go
on and on so Aristotle must have
something different in mind than merely
acquiring this kind of skill when he
talks about teaching he must mean
something like teaching by means of
explaining what the causes or general
principles are so that the the other
person isn't just able to produce
certain results but they understand why
those results are produced why they are
effects of those causes that's the kind
of teaching that he's talking about the
very last thing that I'll mention is is
Aristotle establishes the kind of
hierarchy so the person with art or
science knows more is closer to wisdom
than the person who merely has
experience but we can also talk about
people having arts or sciences that are
subordinated to each other it uses a
term architect tone it's the word that
we get architect from and in an
old-fashioned sense the architect is not
just somebody who drew up you know
blueprints and then said hey go at it
make the house or something like that
you know create the building the
architect oversaw the entire process of
building the building and in overseeing
it the architect the
architect on the ruling technical person
is ruling over all of the other
technical people who have their
subsidiary arts or sciences so we could
think of other things as being
architectonic in that sense Plato
Aristotle rather will talk about
political science in the ethics as being
architect owned in that way because it
decides what all the other Arts and
Sciences within the city do and what
their points and purposes and priorities
are so Aristotle thinks that whoever is
the architect own the person who has the
ruling art or skill they are closer to
wisdom than the person who merely has
the subsidiary art or science but both
of them are further along on the way to
wisdom than the person who merely has
experience
you